Selamlar sevgili arkadaşlar. Umarım
iyisinizdir. Ailenizle birlikte güzel
zamanlar geçiriyorsanızdır iyi iş
fırsatlarını yakalamışsınızdır.
Eğer umutsuzluklarınız varsa da sektör
içerisinde umarım kısa zamanda
çocuğulur. Ekiplerde de çalıştığınız
yerlerde de menin karşılığını
alıyorsunuzdur umarım. Şimdi arkadaşlar
Factory Masterclass'a full focus devam
ediyoruz. Bugünkü Refactor Master
Class'ın yeni serisinde, yeni videosunda
size state management kısmını
anlatacağım. Ve bunu anlatırken aslında
temel olarak base aldığım yapıyı neleri
kurguladığımı size gösteriyor olacağım.
Bunu kibit'le yani blokla yaptığım bir
yapı ve ama bunun dışında yapışımım
aslında bütün hepsinde
kullanabileceğiniz şeyler hepsini burada
göreceksiniz. Eee bunun akabinde yine bu
videonun içerisinde sizin bulacağınız
şeyler aslında Flutter ve Blockla state
management yaklaşımı. Bunun içerisinde
küçük sayfalar yönetirken bodyable'da
daha basit state yönetimi üstüne e bir
konteyner yani as zaten önceden
yapmıştık. Daha global bir state sayfa
yönetimini konuşuyor olacağız ve
bunların promptu ve skilleri ve hepsi
yine videonun sonunda sizinle geliyor
oluyor olacak arkadaşlar. Eee şimdiden
hoş geldiniz içeriye. Şimdi ben size
özetle öncelikle kafamdaki yapıyı şurada
bir çizdirdim. Ne anlatmak, ne yapmak
istedim? Bugüne kadar birçok projede
neden hani eee bu tarz bir yaklaşımı
kullandığımızı da anlatıyor olacağım.
Üstüne de yazdığımız kodlardan,
yazdırdım nazırlattığım yapıdan size
mimari aktarı olacağım ve rahat rahat
siz de bunu kullanabiliyor olacaksınız.
Şimdi arkadaşlar şöyle bir şey var. Yani
bu sektörde olduğum flutter tarafında
yazdığım her dakikada en çok duyduğum
kavram işte state management, state
management olup aslında olayın state
management olmadığını bilen birçok zaten
geliştirici globalde de birçok insan bu
olduğunu bilir ama işte genel olarak hep
böyle bir korku algı var. Bu algının
dışına çıkarak arkadaşlar önemli olan
kullandığınız paket hiçbir zaman için
bir paket sizin önünüze yazdığınız
framework'ün yazdığınız projenin önüne
geçmemeli. Geçiyorsa zaten orada bir
problem var. Burada önemli olan şey
yaklaşım. Bu yaklaşımı yaparken birçok
yaklaşım çeşitleri, kullanım teknikleri
ve yaklaşımların getirisi, artısı,
eksisi olur. Burada en çok mesela işte
Riverpot'la provider, Riverpot'la blog
konuşabilirsiniz. Riverpot baktığınızda
doğrudan metot ve herhangi bir sınıf
object oranted bile olmadı doğrudan
erişebiliyorsunuz. Bu size bir
performans kalemi getirir ama yönetim
zorluğu ve başka çeşitli memori
sorunları çıkartabilir. Bunların da
çözümleri var. Ama mesela bir tarafta da
class instance üzerinden mesela
bloklarınızı yaparsınız. Bu da size işte
o da yine tanımlarında yazar işte heavy
işte daha ağır class instance olduğu
için yer kapladığını söyler. Bunlara çok
takılmadan ben size bu projede eee benim
size en önereceğim bir best practice
olarak bir flutter flutterdaki block
libraryini kullanarak bunun da
içerisinde kübit olayını entegre edip
rahat rahat sınıflarınızı temiz temiz
yarınlara işte ekleyeceğiniz yerlere
neden demesine yönetmenizi size
gösteriyor olacağım. Aslında işin temel
özeti şu şekilde. Eee, benim iki tane
aslında benim sayfa olarak düşündüğümde
üç yaklaşım var. Birinci yaklaşımım
bütün projenin yönetildiği state dediğim
asıl state o aslında. Yani bu nedir?
Mesela temalar projenin bütün globalinde
etkiler. Localization ama mesela servis
taraflı bir localization yapıyorsanız bu
buraya etkiler. Akabininde mesela
projenin genelinde sayfalarda işte belli
başlı kullandığınız versiyon infoları
vesaireler yine buralarda olabilir. Bu
global configlerde bir de user config
daima olur. User bazı işler yapıyorsanız
userın işte belli logiklerini buralarda
saklarsınız. Bu da projenin her yerine
değiştirebilir. Bunlar globaldir benim
için. Bir de sayfa bazlı ben bakarım
olaylara. Mesela bu login clientı, login
sayfası için ben bir sayfanın yönetimini
konuşmaya bakarım. Bunun için de basit
bir alt classla işi yönetirim. Son
olarak da sayfanın içerisindeki bir
butonda bir şey yapacaksam artık
setelerden tamamen elimden geldiği kadar
uzaklaşıp value listeninable buerlar
yaparak sayfanın yönetimini tamamıyen,
en performanslı, en olması gereken
şekline uygun şekilde eee geliştirmiş
olurum. Temel yaklaşım bu şekilde.
Burada da aslında ondan bahsediyor. İşte
product container'da bir getit yani
zaten bunu önceden bu getitir product
containerladır arkadaşlar. Bir önce de
zaten anlattığım şeylerdi aslında
projenin içerisinde var. Daha doğrusu
şeye bakacağım yanlış hatırlamıyorum. He
getit kısmına daha girmemişim şu an.
Belki konteyner kısmına daha
girmeyeceğim. Basitçe göstereceğim. Onu
daha detaylı konuşuyor olacağım. Hani
buradaki amacım aslında bir konerize
yani kontainerize yapıp projenin her
yerine erişebileceğim yani basit bir
aslında kutu açıp kutuda yönetiyor gibi
düşünebilirsiniz. Her yerden koyup
oranın da rahat rahat değiştiğinde bütün
projelerin kendisini anlayabileceği bir
katman olarak düşünebilirsin. Oraya çok
takılmayın ama orada mesela temayı oraya
koydum. Şimdi göstereceğim. Ama benim
asıl olayım mesela sayfam başladığında
login sayfası için bir login create
edeceğim. Login sayfasının bir creatorı
olacak. İşte blog provider'la deniyor
bu. Bunu oluşturacağım ve sayfalar alt
dallarda bu oluşuları doğrudan o kontak
üzden yakalayıp kendine göre
olacaklarını yapacaklar ve ben bunu çok
rahat birkaç hareketle yönetiyor
olacağım. Şimdi gelelim şimdi şuradan
benim yaptığım sayfam arkadaşlar. Login
page. Bir önce de aslında loginle
çalışmıştık. login page. Artık ben bu
işlemi yaparken benim sayfamda
kullanırken ben kubitlerimi yani aslında
sayfanın en root'unda neyi
oluşturacaksam burada create adımıyla
kullanıyorum ve içerisine de ben neyi
login yapacaksam aslında kubit dediğim
kısım benim için business manager'dır.
Yani business nedir mesela? Login olmak
bir businessest'tir. Yani işte senin
işte katmanın erişir, bir şeyler yapar.
Bunları burada yönetiyor oluyorum ve
bunlardan gelen sonuçları da UI'ya
buradan paslıyorum. Bu benim için
business ve UI katmanını yönetme şekli.
Şayet sadece UI'dan UI olsaydı bunu da
işte alt yapacağım vücutlarla veya value
listeninablelarla yönetiyor oluum.
Oluyor olurdum. Eee burada da arkadaşlar
basit bir şekilde işte network manager
instance'ımı burada eee parametre olarak
yollamışım. Burada gördüğünüz gibi işte
product network manager üzerinden bir
istek yollamışım. Şunu da büyütek
göstereceğim. Şimdi onu geçeceğim.
Burada önemli olan kavram arkadaşlar şu
buradaki yaklaşımda sevgili arkadaşlar
eee benim builderımın şu buildera gerek
yok aslında bunu fazladan eklemiş de
buradaki blog listener benim için çok
önemli. Listener'la ben aslında sayfamın
içerisindeki olan hareketleri yani
mesela diyelim sizin bir stateinizden
bir hareket geldi. Tak bunu yakalayıp
bunu kullanmak şeklinde listenlerle veya
ileride kullanacağınız block
selectörlerle yani block selectör mesela
ne işte senin şimdi ben burayı daha
detaylı anlatacağım. daha spesifik
itemları almaya yönelik hareketler
yaptığında bunlar senin hayatını
kurtarıyor olacak. Arkadaşlar önemli
kullanımlar bunlar. Bunların hepsi
gerçekten kendine has, önemli yerlere
sahip. Burada mesela ben şöyle bir best
practice de yapıyorum. Ben kendi
projelerimde kullanırken. Bu niye orayı
açmadı ya? İlla şuraya atıyor.
Heh. Şu kilitlenmiş miydi ki onlar?
Şunun kilidini kaldır. Heh. Tamam. Okey.
Mesela ben şu best practice'imde şunu da
yapıyorum. Ben mesela late final
diyorum. Login cubit diyorum. Mesela
cubitimi şurada oluşturuyorum. Eee, bunu
neden burada böyle yapıyorsun
diyeceksin. Şöyle bir avantajı oluyor.
Mesela şu builderın içeris bu ne? Nereye
attı? Şu builder aslında hiç gerek yok
orada. O builder biraz dümenden gelmiş
oluyor. O kodda diyelim gelmişken
sileyim. Şu blocker zaten şuraya yetecek
ya. O blackin de aslında dolay şu an
için gerek yok da. Hadi izim şu anlık
var olsun. Şuraya geldiğimde de ben bir
şurada bir login işlemim var. Zaten
instanceim yukarı da doğrudan ona
erişebilirim. Buraya vereceğim. Hop.
Burası şu an benim için çalışıyor
olacak. Tamam. Çok iyi. Bir daha yeniden
başlattığımda şurası gelecek şimdi bana.
Şimdi burada önemli olan açı arkadaşlar.
Ha bu şey bu tasarım hatası. Bunu
düzelteceğiz zaten. İkonu bulamıyor da.
Burada önemli olan şey şu kübit
classınızı oluşturup alt
widgetlarınızdan da durumları yönetmek.
durumları işte bir senaryoda mesela
error'u göstermeniz gerekiyor. Mesela
burada error textlerinizi yönetmeniz
yöneteceğim kısım mesela diyelim şurada
bir login state sectionım var. Bakın
burada işte error mesaj varsa state
üzerinden okuyup bunları ekrana
gösterme, en alt daldan erişme hani bir
daha her yerden data paslamadan bunları
alabilme vesaire aslında bildiğimiz
standart flutter yaklaşımlarını aslında
yine cubit ve provider blok aracıyla
bunları kullanıp ekranımıza bağlıyoruz.
Yani temel konseptimiz ana kubitimiz
bizim w model oluyor. State'imizse bunun
içerisindeki yönettiğimiz kısımsa bunun
içerisinde yaptığımız logicler mesela
nedir? Loading'i, error mesajı, is
accessi veya işte çeşitli seneleri varsa
burada tutuyor. Bu yaklaşımlarda yine
burada çok fazla detay teknik olarak
bunları anlattığım videolar var.
Girmeden burada önemli olan nokta ben bu
yaklaşımı seviyorum. Mesela bir sınıf
instance yani bir class instınance yapıp
bunu immutable yapıp hani şuraya hatta
immutable şeyini de atarım. Şöyle bunu
table yapıp ben copy bitlerle aslında
bunun bir dip copyerini copyerini
oluşturup e yeni yeni her defasında
yenisini yollayarak fark yoksa da
sayfamın yenilenmesini engelleyerek
oynuyorum. Bunun bana avantajı şu
oluyor. Mesela ben buraya gelip işte
block selector yazıyor olsaydım mesela
ve deseydim ki sadece state'in
içerisindeki is loading'i al. Mesela
state'in bak şurada neyin var mesela?
Error mesajı al. Şuraya da gelip mesela
şey diyebilirdim. Bulun mesela tamam mı?
Şuraya da is loading diyebilirdim. Bu da
şu anlama geliyor. Mesela blok
kullanımlarında. Ha kardeşim isloading'e
biri bir şey yollamadığı sürece bu vücut
bir daha kendi render etmez mesela gibi
böyle çok efektif kullanabilirsiniz.
Mesela buraların hasta yönetimi de eee
iyidir aslında bu kullanımlar iyidir.
Mesela burada gelip yine yaklaşım olarak
şöyle bir şey var. Yani bir teknik
olarak ben burayı düzelttirecek olsaydım
hani bunu e ile bu taraf burada gidip
bir tane block builder yapıp bu şekilde
yapılmaz aslında. Login error tex'te
gelirsin. Eğer böyle bir hani güzel
parçalamışsın burayı. Sevdim bunu.
Buraya dersin ki ben bir tane block
selector atarım abi buraya. Buna da bu
login cubit state'lerini verirsin. State
no error mesajı verirsin mesela. Burada
da error message. If burası işte mesela
burası if state emptye ise geri
döndersin. Bak mesela şimdi o yukarıda
yazdığımız bir kod vardı. İşte error
mesaj not artık şu koddan kurtulduk.
Kendi kendine yönetiyor zaten. Mesela
diyelim looting'e mi ihtiyacı var? Kimin
ihtiyacı var? Bunun o zaman zaten burada
kullanıyorsan buna burada yollamana
gerek yok kardeşim dersin. Ben niye bunu
burada yollayayım abi? Ben dersin ki bak
geleyim buraya yine bu selectörü
kullanayım ki doğru stateimi yönetmiş
olım. Loading atayım. Hop şurada if
loading caseindeyse loading gözüksün. Şu
kodtan da kurtardı mı burayı kurtardım.
Sonra ben yukarıya geldiimde artık ne
yapabiliyorum? Diyorum ki hocam ben niye
boşu boşuna isloading yolluyorum? Niye
boşu boşuna error mesaj yolluyorum?
Zaten error mesaj orada var. Bak şunu da
sildim. Hop buradan geldim. Bunları
sildim ve kullanmıyor ki. Çünkü burada
zaten state olarak yani state dediğimiz
şey mesaj aslında. Hop ne oldu? Hem
burada immutable'lık kazandım hem
gereksiz yere data paslamaktan kurtardım
hem de block builderı aslında
kullanmıyorum. Zaten burası kendi içinde
bu işi yapıyor. Bak tertemiz size bir
örnek gösterdim. Tamamen konsept ve
amacımız bu. Buradaki sizin yapmanız
gereken sayfaları yaparken bakmanız
gereken hareket bu. Şimdi çok ufak da
hemen login kubimizin üzerinden ne
yapıyoruz diye onu göstereyim size.
Aslında buradaki yaptığımız hareket çok
basit. Biz sadece şeyler yapıyoruz. Yani
ne instınance'lar topluyorsak bunların
ne bileyim promptları var ya da daha
detaylı anlatımları var. Bunun üzerine
onun için çok girmiyorum. Kanalda bir
sürü var bunlar. Buradaki amacım aslında
basitçe bir network manager ve burada
authentication service koymuşum. Ben bu
authentication serviceime login
oluyorum. Burada gördüğünüz gibi login
isteğimi atıyorum. Login isteğimi
attıktan sonrasında ben işlemimi
bitiriyorum. İşlemi bitirdikten
sonrasında yani bütün logiklerim bitti.
Artık oyundayım veya problem var. Bu
geçen hafta yaptığım ders anlatmıştım.
Network managerda error gelirse error'ü
gösteriyorum. Success gelirse success
durumlarındaki senaryolları yapıp işte
network manager'a mesela login olduğu
için bunu verme senaryosunu yapıyorum.
Ardından mesela responsum nal değil.
Yani başarılıyım. Buradaki başarılı
senaryosunda save chinglerini yapıyorum
ve işlemlerimi yaptıktan sonra mesela
save user cash yapıyor. Şu preferen şu
kodda yanlış. Bunu da düzelteceğiz
buraya. Bu şekilde yazılmaz tabii ki.
Bunu da to the database diyeceğim.
Database kısmında göstereceğim size
bunları. Şu K'ler de burada yanlış.
Mesela şunlar da to the localizable
olması lazım. Localization olması lazım
bunların hepsi. E bunları zaten ben
günün sonunda, videonun sonunda
alacağınız prompta bunları da burada
gördüğümde düzeltip size o prompta
düzeltilmiş hepsiyle olan halini veriyor
olacağım. Rahat olabilirsiniz. Yani
buradaki amacımız aslında dediğim gibi o
businessları, fonksiyonları onlarını
yazıp aslında burada işte haber vermek.
Haber verdikten sonra gelen sonuçları
yine emit ederek ekrana işte is loading
false başarısız. Is loading true is true
demek ki başarılı olmuş. İşte senin
sayfanda ne var mesela login listener
yazmıştık hatırlarsanız şurada bak şu
navigate the listener mesela bu navigate
the listener ne olacak aslında if state
successe kardeşim git login ol işte
uygulamaya giriş yap navigate the first
de mesela buradan oyununu hareket ettir
yani ben mesela buraya gelip şuradan
user test dediğimde şuradan girdiğimde
arkadaşlar
hop 1 2 3 4 5 6 dediğimde
email veya şifre hatalı dedi. Burada şey
herhalde bir şurada bir trimsiz
yolluyoruz ondan dolayı. Ha mesela gitti
tak oyuna girdik ve burayı bağlamış
olduk. Yani buradaki temel akış sayfanın
kullanacağı itemları state olarak
tutuyoruz. Bunların imut table
yapıyoruz. İçerisini copyitlerle haber
veriyoruz. Cubit'lerimizde metotlarımızı
tutuyoruz. Cubit'in içerisine view
objecti koymuyoruz. Çünkü business'e
odaklı gidiyoruz. Haber veriyoruz. Eğer
view'la alakalı bir şey varsa listenerda
yakalıyoruz. Diser kennı yapıyor ve
burayı tamamlıyoruz. Diyelim ki hocam
benim global bir şeye ihtiyacım oldu.
Mesela buradaki tema gibi bak bu temayı
tak değiştiriyorum. Bunu yaparken de bu
sefer artık main dart üzerinden gidiyor
olacağım. Neden? Çünkü eee benim tema
olayım bakıldığında bak şurada burada
benim bir tema hareketimin olması lazım.
Yani ben tema nerede? Bak tem mod
şurada. Görüyor musun? Buradanmış. Yani
bu tem mod nasıl almış olabilir? Bu time
modu alabilmesi için arkadaşlar benim
sayfamın globalinde bunun tanımlı olması
lazım. Bunu da aslında global objeleri
tanımladığım yer şu şekilde oluyor.
Block provider dediğim yerde ben eee
global objelerimi tanımlıyorum. Ben
bunun eğer main data yani main appimin
içerisine koyarsam projenin her yerine
eriştirebilir oluyor aslında benim için
bu. Yani önemli olan kısım zaten
buradaki aslında yapılması gereken
hareket veya benim olması gereken nokta
bu. Burada sadece yanlış olan şey
aslında burada block ya value'yu
oluşturduğu için value de verilebilir
ama daha best practice tavsiye edilen
block provider şu şekilde create etmeyi
daha e çünkü burada bir creation
yapılıyor bakıldığında şöyle application
mesela şu şunu alırsam şuradan
application bitti şu kısmı daha detaylı
anlatacağım onu boş verin. O bir konta
etme. Merak ederseniz
araştırabilirsiniz. Şunu baştan
başlatalım. Şurada konteynerın içerisine
koyduk. Şuradan göreceğiz şimdi
geldiğinde.
Aynen. Bunu koyduk. Buradan sonrasında
burayı bağladık. Mesela şurde block
builder değil de demin sizde
göstermiştim mesela hocam burada block
builder di selector atsaydım mesela
burada th mod deseydim zaten burada tem
mod burada bana geliyordu. Ha burası
doğrudan hazır. Burada bir tane şey
kaydı belki de. Heh mesela böyle daha
temiz ve daha güzel kullanımla bizde
olurdu. Şimdi bu yaklaşımın da global
kullanımı. O global kullanımın
diğerinden hiçbir farkı yok. tamamlayan
aynı yine emit etme, yine haber verme ve
yine sayfayı yönlendirmek üzerine. Bunun
içerisine yarın yeni objeler işte
state'in içerisine yeni gelecek
durumları da ekleyip işte bunun
tamamıyetini burada yapacağımız,
projenin her yerini etkileyeceği
hareketleri burada konumlandırıyor
olacağız. Aslında genel bakıştaki
yaklaşımımız hep bu şekilde olacak.
Bizim burada bir tane mesela şeyler de
göstereyim. Vall enableerdan
da bir tane şuradan göstereyim bir.
Şurada bir yerde kullanmıştık onu da.
Şu skillin bak mesela şurada göstereyim
size. Login şu login buton için bak
login buton için yapmışım mesela login
butonunun içerisinde ben mesela işte
login butonu loading case yaptım
muhtemelen. Şuradan bakayım expanded şu
e he o test accountı göster kısmı vardı
şurası mesela bu bir viw business.
Tamam. Bunun için özellikle gidip ekstra
kodlar yazmaya gerek yok. Bunu derim ki
ben geleyim bunu bu tarafta yöneteyim ki
en azından bu logic dışarıdan veya
state'ten veya business'ten olmasına
gerek yok. Mesela bunu yaparken ne
yapmışım? Mesela buradaki kodu
yazdırdığımda text account expanded.
İşte burada gitmiş mesela yukarıdan
almış mesela gördüğünüz gibi biraz
yukarıya çıkmış mesela. Buraya gideyim
mesela nerede bu test user expanded?
Bakın buradan almış. Mesela bakıldığında
aslında bunu buradan silmiş olsaydım
mesela normalde olması gereken senaryoyu
söylüyorum size. Buradan silmiş olsaydım
ha burada toggle varmış ama global
yönetildiği için buraya almış. Normalde
bunu da yönetmenin bir teknik yolu var
da önemli değil. Yani sayfada bir alt
dallarda işlem yaptığınız senel
süreçlerde sayfayı aslında inheritta
benim anlattığım advance kısmında bunun
da daha güzel yolu var da hadi diyelim
onu yapmadık. Bunu daha güzel yapma
anlamında biz burada gelip böyle ufak
alt sınıflarla alt işte volume
notifierlarla yönetiyor olursak müthiş.
Burada bir tricky arkadaşlar birden
fazla volume notifierınız varsa volume
notifier'a bir state
tanımlayabilirsiniz. Bu sayede alt
dallar bunu da oradan alır. Bir de
burada mesela text account expanded
notifier olması lazım ki bunun
bakıldığında mesela o mesela obsecure
password notifier olması lazım ki mesela
burası daha güzel gözüksün. Yani sonuçta
burasının daha okunaklı ve anlaşılması
adına buraların şöyle yapılması
gerekiyor ki burası okunma anlamında
daha iyi olsun. Mesela bunlar da aynısı.
Çünkü doğrudan bunu deyince
anlaşılmıyor. Notifirey deyince o konu
anlaşılıyor mesela gibi. Bunları da
burada eklemiş olduk. Yani aslında
sevgili arkadaşlar bu videonun günün
özetinde çok daha dediğim gibi eee
prompt ve bulacağınız şey sayfaya
başladığınızda sayfanın hayatını bir
kübitlerle globaldeki yaklaşımı da
kübitlerle yapıp bunu state classlarıyla
emit ediyoruz. Eğer global bir objemiz
varsa mesela şurada getitle alakalı
olarak da bir yerimiz var. Şurada mesela
şeyde gösterdik orada.
Şuraya gideyim. Ha project container
setup. Bak project container diye bir
yerimiz var. Project konteinerımızın
yerinde arkadaşlar bunları da konuşuyor
olacağız. Global objelerimizi tutuyoruz
her yerden işlemek için. Container mükas
depend yani ne yapıyoruz biz? Üst
taraftan yani en globalde tanımlıyoruz
bunları. İşte network managerlarımızı,
oyumuzu buyumuzu. Projenin her yeri bu
instance'ları kullanıyor ki yarın yeni
bir şey olduğunda tak 10 yeri 1000 yeri
değiştirmeyelim. Bir anayede oynatalım
proje devam etsin diye aslında bunları
yapıyoruz. Rahat rahat test edebilelim.
Temel fikir daima bu zaten. Bu şekilde
burada bir kullanım var. Bunun üzerinde
duracağız zaten. Şunu
umursamayabilirsiniz.
Ve günün sonunda aslında bakıldığında
sayfanız temiz işte yönetilmeye açık. Ne
yapacağınızı gördünüz. İşlemlerin hangi
akışta yapacağınızı anlayacağınız ha alt
küçük şeylerde volable büyükte kübit
işte şurada bunu yapmam lazım ne neredey
tak diye bulabileceğiniz yaklaşım
sizinle birlikte gelmiş oluyor sevgili
arkadaşlar demiş olayım ben. Şimdi
mesela şu anki halini şu şekilde ben bir
komikli olacağım. Eee şuradan
bir bulabilirsek komitimizi üretirse.
Süper komitimi üretti. Ben bunu buraya
pushlıyorum. Şimdi bu şey yaptıktan
sonrasında bak rejection attı. Internal
server mü? Wow. Bakarım ben buna. E
şimdi bu rejection da bittikten
sonrasında bunu yolladıktan sonra şu
isimlendirmeler işte birkaç tane
gördüğüm prompta da bunları fixletirim.
prompt halinde ve sizin göreceğiniz
skill dosyasında benim yaptığım her şeyi
çok rahat çok hızlı bir şekilde
kullanabileceğiniz yani bir flatter
projesini açtığınızda bu skilliği
kullanarak bu promptü kullanarak rahat
rahat işte kübetini işte state
management yöntemini hızlıca
kullanabileceğiniz temiz bir şekilde
mimari olarak da yaklaşım olarak da
yapabileceğiniz eee bir assasin bir e
dosyamız e yardımcı toolumuz da sizinle
e yardımcı hizmet de sizinle oluyor
olacak çok rahatlıkla proje içerisinden
buna erişebileceksiniz. demiş olayım.
Arkadaşlar tekrardan izlediğiniz için
teşekkür ediyorum. Sevin bir sonraki
videomda artık görüşmek üzere. Kolay
gelsin. Kendinize iyi bakın.